you welcome to this video playing KS
here with white what can I do make it
back to somebody for could play a queen
pawn opening what about this Toria tech
something in something solid okay I
think it's probably good idea to get
some kind of porn lever in the center
that looks a lot like oh no again I
already have some problems sometimes
with the mouse I wanted to go see text
e5 of course ok ok it's not that
terrible but it wasn't it wasn't my
intention guy wants to go e5 here yeah
so let's go here night h5 I have this
move I think looks funky but I get an
8-3 Bishop h2
d5 Bishop d6 it's not possible i think
it takes you four is good yeah but i
think i can just take a couple of times
for a decent position at stake and
Knight f3 I'm actually as a specialist
Quincy three ok let's look at this night
there so castles he cannot prevent 9499
f 394 anyway so i can cancel d 493
blunders upon 94 might be a move okay
hmm Queen d4 is also interesting yep
let's do that let's do that it's an
interesting interesting option queen is
not bad on deform
now that's a good move that's just a
good move here he trades off his bad
Bishop
ok let's continue with that plan it
doesn't it doesn't really net that much
but I don't have many alternatives to
the queenside play
change seven is a mysterious move here
going into the the pin so if i take c 6
and then go to be seven job
d 4 is really a weakness but not sure he
doesn't get the night quickly to f5 or
he six takes takes quite a while
there will be seven now taking the
airport ok so here for Rupe c7 prevented
that so we probably will try to regroup
this night somehow how to do this now
for me now night my deaf slight h7 and
so on over to h 3's may be right
ok let's go to f5 then
now we cannot move the night easily
because h5 is hanging
here
yeah that looks okay right with that
take age five and I planned that
beforehand right that's stupid very
strange I mean I had seen this I'm up
that I'm okay here but why not just take
h5 if it's much easier and was what I
planned okay not a for loop before traps
the night so he has to go back now I can
take it go look II sound okay everyone
you have 392 is not such a great idea
take a rookie 7 rook e8
I think getting the King here it's not
bad rook the age maybe t8 was
interesting rook 28 was much better
wow it looks like maybe a poor chick
meeting ideas yet his King isn't exactly
active okay so a cheeky form yeah check
if all right so check no reason not to
King d5 rookie services one way to run
into a checkmate um okay if I go here
now that it's okay rookie three you can
play a four but what is the big point
check threatening made checking down a
challenge okay it was something entirely
different with the challenge hmm that
was a weird game from here yeah here
this is just okay for black think it's a
not equal big stakes and here so how
does he keep it i mean look ahead is a
passer I don't know but even here I'm
not sure g 3g fiber GG i was definitely
wrong but i'm not sure if he has how how
good this is if he my idea was that he
tries to knock them tries to get to one
of those two square so i thought back
here and then I'm going over here that's
the big point I have to control those
squares and from here it is very noisy
em I have a five I can group c seven
black is in big trouble I know it is
very very passive here this is set up
with Lucy aid and everything
rook a eight also what about this can
you play like this maybe something like
that that's probably a better defense
I'd like to check this Bishop gh5 moth
was ridiculous I was seeing that before
but then I forgot about to move somehow
and now 92 is much stronger this is not
good 92 m for this and this I have to do
this move that's not not clear all yeah
I saw Bishop takes age five and then I
didn't then play it yeah and here he s
uo look T aid I am here to play a five
so that this is a good covering move
until I am really better I easily get
default covered can enter with the King
and I have the much better game because
of my active rooks and King it was a big
mistake I looked yet I saw that but I
didn't see a five I was just saying okay
this is what I have to do and yeah but
this is just much much better here I
think I'm quite clearly better jump and
winter and wins okay well thanks for
watching